Lo que voy a hacer, en el espíritu de creatividad colaborativa,
es simplemente repetir muchos de los puntos
que las tres personas antes de mi ya han tocado.
Pero hacerlo --
esto es llamado creatividad colaborativa;
es pedir prestado.
Pero hacerlo a través de cierta perspectiva,
y eso se refiere a hablar del rol de usuarios y consumidores
en este mundo emergente
de la creatividad colaborativa
que Jimmy y los demás han hablado.
Déjenme hacerles, para empezar,
esta sencilla pregunta:
¿quién inventó la bicicleta de montaña?
Porque la teoría económica tradicional diría,
que la bici de montaña fue probablemente inventada por una gran compañía,
que tenía un gran laboratorio
en donde se pensaban los nuevos proyectos,
y que salió de ahí. No salió de ahí.
Otra respuesta podría ser, que provino de un genio solitario
trabajando en su cochera, quien,
trabajando en diferentes tipos de bicicletas, llegó
a esta bici de la nada.
No salió de ahí. La bicicleta de montaña
viene de los usuarios; vino de usuarios jóvenes,
particularmente de un grupo del norte de California,
que estaban frustrados con las bicicletas de carreras tradicionales,
que eran el tipo de bicis que Eddy Merckx montaba,
o tu hermano mayor, y que eran muy glamorosas.
Pero también estaban frustrados con las bicis de sus papás,
que tenían manubrios grandes y eran muy pesadas.
Entonces, tomaron los cuadros de estas bicicletas,
los ensamblaron con los piñones de la bicicletas de carrera,
tomaron los frenos de las motocicletas,
y mezclaron y revolvieron varios ingredientes.
Por los primeros, no sé, tres a cinco años de su vida,
las bicicletas de montaña eran conocidas como "chatarreras" (clunkers)
Eran hechas solamente en una comunidad de ciclistas,
principalmente en el norte de California.
Y luego una de estas compañías que importaba partes
para las chatarreras decidieron hacer negocio,
empezando a venderlas a otra gente,
y gradualmente surgió otra compañía, Marin,
y probablemente tomó, no sé,
10 o tal vez hasta 15 años,
antes de que las grandes compañías de bicicletas
se dieran cuenta de que había mercado.
30 años después,
las ventas de bicicletas de montaña,
y equipo para bicicletas de montaña,
representan el 65 por ciento de las ventas de bicicletas en Estados Unidos.
Eso es 58 mil millones de dólares.
Esta es una categoría completamente creada por los consumidores,
que no hubiera sido creada por el mercado de bicicletas principal
porque no podía ver la necesidad,
la oportunidad;
no tenían el incentivo para innovar.
La única cosa con la que creo que no concuerdo
sobre la presentación de Yochai
es cuando dijo que Internet genera
esta capacidad distribuida para innovar.
Es cuando internet se combina
con este tipo de consumidores "pro-am" --
que son conocedores, que tienen el incentivo para innovar,
que tienen las herramientas, que ellos quieren --
que tienes este tipo de explosión
de creatividad colaborativa.
Y de eso obtienes la necesidad del tipo de cosas
de las que Jimmy hablaba, que es nuestro nuevo tipo de organización,
o una mejor forma de decirlo:
como nos organizamos nosotros mismos sin las organizaciones?
Eso ahora es posible; no necesitas una organización para ser organizado,
para realizar tareas grandes y complejas,
como innovar en nuevos programas de software.
Así que este es un gran reto
a la forma en que pensamos como se origina la creatividad.
La postura tradicional, todavía cimentada
en mucho de la manera en la que pensamos sobre creatividad
-- en organizaciones, en el gobierno --
es que la creatividad se trata de gente especial:
usan gorras de béisbol al revés,
vienen a conferencias como esta, en lugares especiales,
universidades de la élite, laboratorios de investigación en bosques, en el agua,
tal vez en cuartos especiales pintados de colores en las empresas,
ya saben, puffs, o tal vez el peculiar fútbol de mesa.
Gente especial, en lugares especiales, piensan ideas especiales,
entonces tienes una línea de ensamble que toma esas ideas
a los expectantes consumidores, que son pasivos.
Ellos pueden decir "si" o "no" al invento;
esa es la idea de la creatividad.
¿Cuál es la política recomendada para eso
si estas en el gobierno, o si diriges una compañía grande?
Más gente especial, más lugares especiales.
Crea conglomerados creativos en las ciudades;
crea más parques de investigación, y así sucesivamente.
Amplía la línea de ensamble hasta los consumidores.
Bueno esta visión, creo, es cada vez más equivocada.
Creo que siempre ha estado equivocada,
porque creo que la creatividad siempre ha sido altamente colaborativa,
y probablemente de mucha interactividad.
Pero es incrementalmente equivocado, y una de las razones que está mal
es que las ideas fluyen hace arriba de la línea de ensamble.
Que las ideas vienen de los consumidores,
y que frecuentemente están adelante de los productores.
¿Por qué pasa eso?
Bueno, una situación
es que la innovación radical,
cuando tienes ideas que
afectan a un gran número de tecnologías o personas,
tienen incorporadas una gran cantidad de incertidumbre.
Los dividendos a la innovación son mayores
cuando la incertidumbre es más alta.
Y cuando tienes una innovación radical,
es comúnmente poco claro como se puede aplicar.
Toda la historia de la telefonía
es la historia de como tratar con esa incertidumbre.
Los primeros teléfonos de línea terrestre,
los inventores pensaron
que serían utilizados por los usuarios para escuchar
eventos en vivo
de los teatros del West End.
Cuando las compañías telefónicas inventaron el SMS,
no tenían idea para qué era;
no fue sino hasta que la tecnología llegó a las manos
de los usuarios adolescentes
que inventaron el uso.
Así que entre más radical la innovación,
mayor incertidumbre;
y más necesitas la innovación en el uso
para determinar el uso de una tecnología.
Todas nuestras patentes, todo nuestra aproximación
a las patentes y la invención, está basada en la idea
de que el inventor sabe para qué es la invención;
que podemos decir para qué es.
Cada vez más los inventores de cosas,
no podrán decir esto con antelación.
Se determinará en el uso,
en colaboración con el usuario.
Nos gusta pensar que la invención es
un momento de creación:
que hay un momento de nacimiento cuando a alguien se le ocurre una idea.
La verdad es que la mayoría de la creatividad
es acumulativa y colaborativa,
como la Wikipedia, se desarrolla en un largo período de tiempo.
La segunda razón por la que los usuarios son más y más importantes
es que ellos son la fuente de grandes y disruptivas innovaciones.
Si quieres encontrar las nuevas grandes ideas,
es difícil encontrarlas en los mercados principales,
en las grandes organizaciones.
Y sólo vean adentro de las grandes organizaciones
y verán por qué es así.
Así que estas en una gran compañía;
y obviamente quieres subir en la escalera corporativa.
Tu entrarías a la mesa directiva y dirías,
miren, tengo una idea fantástica
para un producto incipiente
en un mercado marginal,
con consumidores que nunca han tratado con ella,
no estoy seguro de que nos va a dar grandes ganancias, pero podría ser, muy muy grande en el futuro?
No, lo que haces es que vas y dices,
Tengo una idea fantástica, para innovación incremental
a un producto existente que vendemos a través de canales existentes
a usuarios existentes, y puedo garantizar
que tendrán esta ganancia por los próximos tres años.
Las grandes compañías tienen una tendencia
a reforzar el éxito del pasado.
Están tan hundidos en él,
que es muy difícil para ellos el encontrar
nuevos mercados emergentes. Entonces los nuevos mercados emergentes,
son el terreno de creación para usuarios apasionados.
El mejor ejemplo:
quién en la industria musical,
hace 30 años, hubiera dicho,
"OK, vamos a inventar un estilo musical
que se trata de hombres negros marginados
en los ghettos expresando su frustración
con el mundo a través de una forma de música
que al principio a muchas personas les será difícil escuchar.
Eso parece una idea ganadora; hay que hacerla".
(Risas).
Entonces: ¿qué sucede? Los usuarios crean el rap.
Lo hacen con sus propias cintas, con su propio equipo de grabación;
lo distribuyen ellos mismos.
30 años después,
la música rap es el estilo musical dominante en la cultura popular --
jamás hubiera venido de las grandes compañías.
Tenía que empezar -- este es el tercer punto --
con estos "pro-ams".
Esta es la frase que he usado en
algunas de las cosas que he hecho
en un laboratorio de ideas en Londres llamado Demos,
donde hemos estado observando a estas personas que son amateur --
o sea que lo hacen por gusto --
pero lo quieren hacer con estándares muy altos.
Y a través de un amplio rango de campos --
desde software, astronomía,
ciencias naturales,
amplias áreas de la cultura y el entretenimiento
como surfeo con cometas, y así más --
encontrarán gente que quiere hacer cosas porque les gusta,
pero las quieren hacer con estándares muy altos.
Trabajan a su placer.
Toman sus pasatiempos muy seriamente:
adquieren competencias, invierten tiempo,
usan la tecnología cada vez más barata: no sólo Internet;
cámaras, tecnología para el diseño,
tecnología de entretenimiento, tablas de surf, y otras cosas.
En gran medida debido a la globalización,
mucho de este equipo se ha abaratado.
Consumidores más conocedores, más educados,
más capaces de conectarse entre ellos,
más capaces de hacer cosas juntos.
El consumo, en ese sentido, es una expresión
de su potencial productivo.
Encontramos el por qué las personas estaban interesadas en esto,
es que no sienten que se expresan en el trabajo.
No sienten como si estuvieran haciendo algo que realmente les importa,
entonces toman este tipo de actividades.
Esto tiene enormes implicaciones organizacionales
para grandes áreas de la vida.
Por ejemplo la astronomía,
algo que Yochai ya había mencionado.
Hace 20 años, hace 30 años,
sólo los grandes astrónomos profesionales
con telescopios muy grandes podían ver lejos hacia el espacio.
Y hay un gran telescopio en el norte de Inglaterra llamado Jodrell Bank,
y cuando era niño, era increíble,
porque las imágenes de la luna arrancaban y esta cosa se movía en rieles.
Y era enorme -- absolutamente enorme.
Ahora, seis
astrónomos amateur, trabajando con Internet,
con telescopios digitales dobsonianos --
que son prácticamente de código abierto --
con unos sensores de luz
desarrollados en los últimos 10 años, Internet --
pueden hacer lo que sólo Jodrell Bank podía hacer hace 30 años.
Así que aquí en la astronomía, tienes esta amplia explosión
de nuevos recursos productivos.
Los usuarios pueden ser productores.
¿Qué significa esto entonces, para nuestro
paisaje organizacional?
Bueno, sólo imagina un mundo,
por un momento, dividido en dos campamentos.
Por un lado, tienes al viejo y tradicional modelo corporativo.
Personas especiales, en lugares especiales;
paténtalo, empújalo por la línea de ensamble
a las expectantes masas de consumidores pasivos.
Por este lado, vamos a imaginar que tenemos
Wikipedia, Linux, y más allá -- código abierto.
Esto es abierto, esto es cerrado;
esto es nuevo, esto es tradicional.
Bueno la primer cosa que puedes decir, con seguridad,
es lo que Yochai ya ha dicho --
es que si hay un gran conflicto
entre esas dos formas organizacionales.
Esta gente de allá van a hacer todo lo que puedan
para frenar el éxito de estos tipos de organizaciones,
porque son amenazados por ellas.
Entonces los debates acerca de
derechos de autor, derechos digitales y todas esas cosas --
se tratan de suprimir, en mi opinión,
este tipo de organizaciones.
Lo que estamos viendo es una corrupción total
de la idea de las patentes y los derechos de autor.
Pensados para incentivar la invención,
Pensados para ser una forma de orquestar la diseminación de conocimiento,
están siendo utilizadas, cada vez más, por las grandes compañías
para crear cercas de patentes
para prevenir que se de lugar la innovación.
Déjenme darles dos ejemplos solamente.
El primero es, imagínense yendo con un inversionista
y decirle: "Tengo esta idea fantástica.
Inventé este brillante nuevo programa
que es mucho, mucho mejor que el Outlook de Microsoft".
¿Qué inversionista en su sano juicio te va a dar dinero para hacer una empresa
que compita con Microsoft, con el Outlook? Ninguno.
Es por eso que la competencia con Microsoft vendrá --
y sólo vendrá --
de un proyecto del tipo de código abierto.
Entonces hay un gran argumento de competencia
acerca del sostener la capacidad
para la innovación impulsada por código abierto y por consumidores,
porque es una de las más grandes
palancas competitivas en contra del monopolio.
Habrá enormes argumentos profesionales también.
Porque los profesionales, por este lado
en las organizaciones cerradas --
pueden ser académicos, pueden ser programadores,
pueden ser doctores, pueden ser periodistas --
mi anterior profesión --
dirán, "No, no puede confiar en estas personas de acá".
Cuando empezé en el periodismo --
en el Financial Times, hace 20 años --
era muy emocionante
el ver a alguien leyendo el periódico.
Y te asomabas sobre su hombro en el metro
para ver si estaban leyendo tu artículo.
Comúnmente estaban leyendo los precios de las acciones,
y el pedazo del periódico con tu artículo
estaba en el piso, o algo así,
y saben, "Cielos, ¿qué están haciendo?
¡No están leyendo mi brillante artículo!"
Y permitimos a los usuarios, lectores,
dos lugares donde podían contribuir al periódico:
la página de cartas, a donde podían escribir una carta
y condescendientemente, cortaríamos a la mitad,
e imprimiríamos tres días después.
O la página de editoriales abierta, donde si conocían al editor --
habían ido a la escuela con él, o se habían acostado con su esposa --
podían escribir un artículo para la página de editoriales.
Esos eran los dos lugares.
¡Qué horror!: ahora, los lectores quieren ser escritores y publicadores.
Ese no es su rol; se supone que deben leer lo que escribimos nosotros.
Pero no quieren ser periodistas. Los periodistas piensan
que los bloguers quieren ser periodistas;
no quieren ser periodistas, sólo quieren tener una voz.
Quieren, como Jimmy dijo, quieren tener un diálogo, una conversación.
Quieren ser parte de ese flujo de información.
Lo que está pasando ahí es que todo el dominio
de la creatividad se está expandiendo.
Así que habrá un gran conflicto.
Pero, también, habrá un movimiento tremendo
de lo abierto a lo cerrado.
Lo que verán, creo, son dos cosas que son críticas,
y estas, creo, son dos retos
para el movimiento abierto.
El primero es:
¿realmente podemos sobrevivir con voluntarios?
si esto es tan crítico,
¿no necesitamos fondearlo, organizarlo y apoyarlo
en formas más estructuradas?
Creo que la idea de crear la Cruz Roja
para la información y conocimiento es una idea fantástica,
¿pero realmente podemos organizar eso sólo con voluntarios?
¿Qué tipo de cambios necesitamos en la política pública
y el fondeo para hacer eso posible?
¿Cuál es el rol de la BBC,
por ejemplo, en ese mundo?
¿Cuál debe ser el rol de la política pública?
Y finalmente, lo que creo que verán
es que las organizaciones cerradas inteligentes,
se moverán cada vez más en la dirección de la apertura.
Así que no será un concurso entre dos campamentos,
pero entre ellos, se van a encontrar todo tipo de lugares interesantes
que la gente ocupará.
Saldrán nuevos modelos organizacionales,
mezclando lo abierto y lo cerrado en formas ingeniosas.
No será tan claro; no será Microsoft contra Linux --
habrá todo tipo de cosas en medio.
Y esos modelos organizacionales, resulta,
que son increíblemente poderosos,
y las personas que los comprendan
serán, muy, muy exitosas.
Permítanme darles un ejemplo final
de lo que significa.
Estaba en Shangai,
en una cuadra de oficinas
construida en lo que era un arrozal hace cinco años --
Uno de los 2.500 rascacielos
que han construido en Shangai en los últimos 10 años.
Y estaba cenando con un tipo llamado Timothy Chen.
Timothy Chen creo un negocio de Internet
en el 2000.
No se fue a Internet, guardó su dinero,
decidió irse a los juegos de computadora.
Administra una compañía llamada Shanda,
que es la compañía de juegos de computadora más grande de China.
Tienen 9.000 servidores en toda China;
hay 250 millones de suscriptores.
En cualquier momento, hay 4 millones de personas jugando uno de sus juegos.
¿Cuántas personas contrata
para dar servicio a esa población?
500 personas.
Bueno, como pueden dar servicio a dos y medio --
250 millones de personas con 500 empleados?
Porque básicamente, no les da servicio.
Les da una plataforma,
les da unas reglas, les da herramientas
y el hace la orquestación de la conversación;
él dirige la acción.
Pero de hecho, mucho del contenido
es creado por los mismos usuarios.
Y esto genera un tipo de pregnancia
entre la comunidad y la compañía
que realmente es muy poderosa.
La mejor medida de eso: cuando entras a uno de sus juegos,
creas un personaje
que desarrollas durante el transcurso del juego.
Si por alguna razón, tu tarjeta de crédito rebota,
o hay algún otro problema,
pierdes tu personaje.
Tienes dos opciones.
Una opción: puedes crear un nuevo personaje,
desde cero, pero sin la historia de tu jugador.
Eso cuesta como 100 dólares.
O puedes tomar un avión, volar a Shangai,
hacer fila afuera de las oficinas de Shanda --
costaría probablemente 600, 700 dólares --
y reclamar tu personaje, obtienes tu historial de regreso.
Cada mañana, hay 600 personas haciendo fila
fuera de sus oficinas
para reclamar estos personajes.
Así que esto se trata de compañías creadas en comunidades,
que proveen a las comunidades herramientas,
recursos, plataformas en las que pueden compartir.
El no es de código abierto,
pero es muy muy poderoso.
Así que este es uno de los retos, creo,
para las personas como yo, que
hacen mucho trabajo con el gobierno.
Si tu eres una compañía de juegos,
y tienes un millón de jugadores en tu juego,
sólo necesitas un porcentaje de ellos
que sean co-desarrolladores, contribuyendo ideas,
y tienes una fuerza de desarrollo
de 10.000 personas.
Imagínense si pudieran tomar todos los niños
en la educación de Gran Bretaña, y el uno por ciento de ellos
fueran los co-desarrolladores de la educación.
¿Qué haría eso a los recursos disponibles
al sistema educativo?
O si el uno por ciento de los pacientes del Servicio Nacional de Salud
se vuelven, en cierto sentido, co-productores de la salud.
La razón por la que --
a pesar de todos los esfuerzos para cortarla,
para detenerla, para contenerla --
estos modelos abiertos seguirán emergiendo
con una fuerza tremenda,
es que multiplican nuestros recursos productivos.
Y una razón por la que lo hacen
es que transforman a los usuarios en productores;
a los consumidores en diseñadores.
Muchas gracias.